hello in this video we'll talk about
microarray analysis
microarray is a tool which can detect
the expression of thousands of genes
simultaneously
microarrays are nothing but a
slide
which has
specific
dna probes
so sometimes they are referred as gene
chips
these slides are printed with thousands
of tiny spots diff at defined locations
each spot contains
known dna sequence which corresponds to
a particular gene and these act as a
probe to detect gene expression
in this video we'll talk about the
application of microarray how microarray
works and the data analysis part so stay
tuned till the end of this video
in order to understand microarray we
first take some examples and then we
would go to step by step analysis
let's say we ask a question how neurons
are different from epithelial cells in
terms of gene expression
or let's say we ask that how a normal
cell differs from a cancer cell when it
comes to transcriptome level
or we ask that how a mature neuron is
different from an immature neuron
all of these kind of questions can be
answered using microarray by looking at
the transcriptome
level
so let's talk about the overall
applications of microarray microarray
can be used for biomedical research
clinical diagnosis pharmaceutical
industry or if even for phylogenetic
analysis and studying evolution
now let's get back to our question and
try to understand microarrays step by
step so we are trying to understand that
how neurons are different from
epithelial cells in terms of gene
expression are there unique genes that
are expressed by one cell but not the
other these are our question
so we first
extract the
total rna from neurons and the
epithelial cells
then
we prepare c dna but while preparing
cdna this particular cdna coming from
neurons and epithelial cells are
differentially labeled
later on we load those cdna samples on
these microarray chips and later on scan
that
with a microarray scanner
ultimately
we analyze the differential expression
pattern of these genes
so this is the overall workflow of
microarray
so the first step for microarray would
be extracting the rna
so first we perform cell lysis and then
we run the lysate through a extraction
column
in this column
the rna molecules bind to the column
material
then we add illusion buffer to this
column
after adding the illusion buffer the rna
is eluted and this pure rna is collected
this rna would be converted to cdna by
performing a reverse transcriptase pcr
if you don't know what is reverse
transcriptase pcr is you can check it in
the i button
then ultimately these cdna samples are
loaded on these microarray chips
let me remind you that in this
microarray chips
the cdna which are loaded
are differentially labeled
for simplicity let us
imagine that the neurons
give rise to these red labeled cdna
whereas the cdna of epithelial cells are
green labeled
so these labels are fluorescent labels
and this can be achieved by using
fluidly labeled nucleotides while
synthesizing the dna
so now
we are zooming into one particular spot
of these microarray chip
now whenever we add
particular c dna this would hybridize to
these portions of this spot
so here we can understand
for probes corresponding to gene a
samples that are coming from the neuron
are hybridizing more compared to samples
coming from the epithelia
and the scenario is different
for the next spot
now all these spots are actually scanned
and analyzed
let us talk about three such spots here
this spot correspond to gene x
here we can understand
that gene x is expressed more in the
neurons
and
less in the epithelial cells
whereas gene y if we imagine it is
expressed more in the epithelial cells
and less in the neurons that is why the
spot looks green
whereas a yellow spot represents the
expression levels are kind of similar in
between these two cell types
now there are thousands of spots in this
array
all of these spots are read or by
automated
scanner machine
and all these informations are added
and analyzed further to extract the data
so the analysis involves making
adjustment for systemic errors including
differences in intensities
then
the normalization of two color arrays is
achieved by local regression
further steps include background
correction scaling as well as averaging
the signals coming from duplicate spots
all of these things are achieved and
ultimately a heat map is generated to
represent the data
here we can see
the neuron and the epithelia are
expressed in two certain columns in
these heat map and the sub columns
represent the technical replicates or
the biological replicates in this case
these are biological replicates
so
and and the right hand side represents
several name of genes or probe ids here
gene i gene a would be corresponding to
a probe id and this is how we can
understand or read the data
here we can understand from the color
key
that this particular genes
are upregulated in epithelia
compared to the neuron whereas these set
of genes are upregulated in neurons
compared to epithelia
now once we have understanding of these
basic aspects we can further
analyze signaling pathway using several
bioinformatics tools
one thing we should always understand
that whenever we perform a microarray
analysis the data has to be submitted
into the gene expression omnibus server
such that it is available to public and
it is available to the researchers
worldwide
so in this video we looked at microarray
and let us try to understand the
limitations of microarray though this
technique appears to be very high
throughput and cutting edge but these
days nobody really use microarray
because rna sequencing is cheaper and
much more efficient
in various aspect in next video we'll
look at rna sequencing as a replacement
of microarray so here are few
limitations
so the reliance upon existing knowledge
about genomic sequence is a big
disadvantage
high background level is a big problem
limited dynamic range of detection can
lead to saturation or
background in the signals that could
compromise the detection
ultimately comparing expression level
across different experiment is often
difficult and cumbersome
for all these limitations microarray
is kind of discontinued by the
researchers worldwide people now prefer
analyzing the rna sequencing data
compared to microarray so in this video
we talked about microarray all the
aspects about microarray
if you like this video please support my
channel in patreon if you are a indian
viewer you can support my channel using
bim upi by scanning this qr code you can
contribute a small amount
to this channel and i really value that
anyway my courses are also present in an
academy which is india's largest online
platform
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe thank you